everyone so tender said I title is
making soccer with sound and today i
want to show you through four examples
software-based interactive musical works
the processes by which these works k
shape and their political balances that
we as inhabitants of software mediated
cultural spaces can gain from support
projects I've selected as case studies
are reflected by Rekha amada thicket by
marking packard jazz computer by Yoda
man and baggage allowance when Pamela
see I'll talk a little about each of
these pieces and their authors in turn
using interview artists as well as close
readings of their code and other
underpinnings and then I'll focus on
four sites where if interactive works
are shaping helping us reckon music
communication and software these topics
are the musical work interactivity
platforms listening I'll make four main
claims about interactive musical works
first but they valorize an already
existing role for the listener and
instigating music awards second that
they lend moral logics to the
development of new media and
interactivity to place within it third
that they contribute to our ability to
critique the platforms where artworks
mean audiences finally that they reject
conceptions old and new a life of
listening as passive so the dive right
in reflective is a musical work by rico
yamada using sounds recorded by Vijay
Iyer the place for one listener at a
time inside a curtain off space in a
gallery as you wait outside that space
for your turn to experience the piece of
diagram drawn in chalk on one of the
gallery vault prepares you blocks of
text surrounding a bird's-eye
representation of the circular space
include entering to the starkness alone
and in this darkness you must decide
take a step or stay still move one sort
of many times East to shoot each
decision leaves traces on your sonic
experience here's an excerpt from you
modest video
so reflective originated with the modest
frustration that her audiences and live
performance settings didn't seem to
fully engage she says she wanted to get
audiences and ability to affect the
piece without requiring any particular
musical literacy from them and thus
selected movement as the perimeter by
which listeners could wield influence on
their sonic experience trained as a
composer Yamada ensure that the case
pertains certain formal aspects of a
musical composition namely that it had a
beginning and the dark solitary
enclosure of the piece suggests an
isolation sound or sight but in fact the
amata reveals that the darkness was her
latest approach to a challenge he
continually faces in your interactive
leases people probe at the piece
frantically testing the extent of their
control when she wants them instead to
experience the peace of the patient
collective attention the darkness is a
way of scaring people she says as a way
of maintenance slow down putting
listeners in that reflective state is so
important to you mod it because what she
wants them to experience is a decision
making process she says I've worked with
imperfection as my very important
aesthetic concept throughout the years
so a lot of people to make the decision
to act upon it and then there's some
kind of resulting sound and I can be
very disturbing at times it can be too
loud where do you sort it or something
like that and then people can step back
to a diversity effect or maybe not
reverse it anymore and to deal with it
for the rest of the time rather than
rewards for mastering pieces interactive
panic the startling change isn't
reflected our transportations from
within the seemingly protective
aesthetic space into the messy everyday
reality of uncertainties
occasions reflective shows us how
interactivity can play a motivated and
thoughtfully conceived roll musical work
the next case study highlights the
special status of software as a medium
for sentry musical works thicket is an
application distributed on Apple's iOS
platform when you first open the
application so that gets most each
combined sound visual visual elements
and touch gestures in shaping a song
like terrain where the listener can both
trigger of mass suicide and get caught
up in the progression Olympics patterns
musician boarding packer and visual list
of John would not develop thicket
together but it wasn't their first
collaboration Hagrid first started
making software in his musical practice
a little after you moved from Boston to
New York and 1990s he'd been active in
the drum bass seen in Boston but felt it
was certainly worth a serpent its
approach to sound looking for something
new saw a musician perform using super
flyer an audio Center programming
language geared towards live coding
Packard started using super collider
heavily in his own music around the same
time we met odd who is also learning to
code for its graphical experiments the
two would work separately on their
software that come together in like a
curtain calls audio-visual transcended
when Apple's iPad was announced both
felt that it was an ideal opportunity to
channel what they already did into a
distributable form think it was the
result the process of making thicket
Packard Co developed a new software
library for audio synthesis that shares
the name of the club reverse
super flattering use tonic tonic is an
open source library for coders plus plus
what are the languages in which
applications while looking at onyx code
one can see that these individual
choices about how software can manage
sound in transmission for our in
transmission from super collider
teutonic through packard we can see
thicket as a point where integrated
cultural systems to use box or else turn
merge one in packages and Alaric Packard
musical practice which takes up sonic
signifiers transmitted bass seem to
Jamaica London pasta and one in the
software layer commending the methods
and priorities of the academic music
tradition for super collider ability
assembled in the software object of the
musical work they did these two systems
meet with the additional presence of iOS
and sub the platform that in supporting
that it imposes its own set of amended
values the next case study give us a
chance to further impact the encounter
particular work in its platform jazz
computers and interactive piece
experience in the web browser as we
vividness the work has both an auditory
and visual player designed and
programmed prospectively go to men and
Sarah rockers here's what happens when
you activate
like Patrick mad maintains an open
source software library for making these
phantom pieces this is called tongue
written in JavaScript it's tailored for
building music that will be experienced
in web browser beyond providing means
for pieces to run and listeners browser
that tone includes interface not
intended seen by listeners the man uses
to sculpt his songs also in the present
man finds great appeal in sss the means
of production and distribution need one
thing I produce in the browser the music
has produced reproduced in the browser
and it's also the method of distribution
over the internet bands engagement with
the browser as a platform mode
production distribution reflects the
role of web admin shaving musical
practice having first incorporated
socrates music by building generative
systems in the visual programming
language maximus p man was intrigued
when we learned about the Web Audio API
at a time and Alaric technology that
enabled in that dynamic sound processes
the browser tone is built on top of that
API tracking some of its functionality
into utilities tailored to interact with
music maddox interest in the web and his
interest in interactivity we wanted the
same he always says he saw that what you
do in the browser was a different
paradigm where the distribution is
instantaneously not just about the sound
barrier but about the interaction
business number the centrality of the
web browser has platform to man's
creative process in general is
emphasized by jazz computer which takes
it which itself takes up and critique of
an empire and shows the isolates
scrolling is the sole motive for
cracking peace asking us to reflect on
the meaning to give that action other
parts of the bed with visual elements
from Robert like lately eloping social
media services complementing listeners
under scrolls are demanding more from
them the piece takes on a satirical
slant towards the figure of the content
p and our compulsion to passively scroll
through it from am the specific platform
of the web browser has been crucial in
shaping it is the technological
capability and the subject of it work
all once
interactivity is not just a tool but
something too impressed it back from the
interfaces that abuse it brought your
music into a more thoughtful exchanging
the final case that we will bring us
from platform toward a consideration
platform ecology this is the web portal
to handle disease intermedia where
baggage allowance as with jazz computer
visitors and capital tease weeping
steamer draw the shoes have their own
suitcase the shoes have their own leave
a steamer trunk
the bottom drawer was always kept locked
the shoes have their own bath this is
vintage assaf hypothesizes big and they
had anybody here are hovering and
clicking rather than scroll for building
grant making baggage allowance lesson
exchange with the web browser itself
than with a set of musical objects these
web objects have visible at marks web
portal visibly one entered iteration of
the whole baggage allowance which also
takes the forms gallery installation
with a live performance here's a photo
of Z in the stage version so you can see
all three iterations of baggage
allowance from the upset and her
construction of each involved
translating elements first realized in
one setting into the others the webpart
portal reflects this translation and
correspondence of its objects arranged
browsable hierarchy to pieces see bill
for the gallery installation however the
hovering mechanism we're moving the
cursor quickly over the many objects
triggers the sort of stereo spread
disease vocal recordings evokes the use
of the sampler a central tool in teas
live performances the web portal best
completes a kind of triangulation among
all three versions of movies in doing so
it calls attention to the differences
between these three privileged contexts
here a term that would most likely be
applied to the web becomes very useful
in assessing all breeding that turning
adams a platform platform ask system
thing about constraints and Hortense's
in a considered difference not just an
informal traits that in their material
conditions one material condition for
the web portal so is the encroaching
obsolescence and flash proprietary
software language with which she played
the piece by both showing work
reiterated across multiple platforms and
demonstrating a particular danger you
need one of those platforms baggage
allowance asks us to think about not
just the spaces but the platform
ecosystems where artworks taking shape
and eat their audiences elements beyond
the artists control includes the
lifecycle of platform specific artworks
and those infrastructural dependence
shouldn't be thought of as separate from
the formal properties of these okay so
the fun part didn't have over the
general significance of these words
let's take a step back to the two
components of the term interactive
musical works the aesthetic philosophy
of music is actually contended for a
long time it turns out with a question
of what people need music will work
whether some separate thing exists that
receives the scores recordings and other
objects through which we encounter
pieces virgina form shows a
destabilization of the work concept in
as she says you're shifting ontology of
contemporary music in vision
technologies play a major role horan
proposes a focus on mediation as the key
to identifying shifts in the dominant
historical boat the musical assembly we
could lay out a mediating chain from a
musical works conception into its
instantiation as a sound stronger that
is natural momentum sound conferring the
world the left side of this diagram have
attempted to do that for a typical song
for used to receive recording apparatus
and save rock music it's a long chain
involving a score recording vessel
element performance that some figured in
abstract synthesis and recorded events
but its final step requires an action
listener activation so limpid a play on
a turntable double double opinion icon
representing a digital audio planning
for example looking at a project league
thicket we see that for interactive
musical works soccer object that
constitutes it is far less removed from
its conception than a score recording
would be mediated chain in fact becomes
much simpler 16 on the right and the
listeners role in instantiating the work
retains its position to change rather
than inventing listeners mediational
involvement already exists in recorded
music authors of interactive where
musical works valorize it by centering
the words themselves on that predation
turning from the musical work to the
other term interactivity we can see how
a particular brought aspect
yeah lately speared in a better
direction by these musical works
pictured here is the musician and
scholar george lewis whose voyager
software exporters possibilities for
computation as an improvisation media
louis race set interactivity has
graduated competitive for information
retrieval rather than dialogue posing
the danger of commodifying and
ultimately prey of my encounter with
technology where Lewis sees his work on
Voyager is capturing that friend with
its aesthetic variation and difference
we can see it works like reflective
great deal of effort being made to bring
a listener into a meaningful
conversation with a carefully designed
mode of interaction the specific musical
properties of reflective such as it's
fixed duration ensure that the attackers
one-way retrieval sensory information
instead a sustained experience in doing
so these works reinforce Francis license
claims that the ways new media
differentiating themselves can be found
on an ology of sound and the rhetorics
of music by stating this aeroplane
interactivity interactive musical works
push back on the slippage of the word
interactivity Lewis appears and that
causes lab manovich precaution I had
some tautological use of the term in
regard to competition medium the
differently opinion though differently
oriented that Lewis's artificial
intelligence system these works join in
in advancing women event halls and open
interactivity one we're not just
elements but whole structure exchange in
dialogue with audience so we've seen
through baggage allowance how
intermediate works can take the notion
of platform from the soccer domain and
asked us to apply it to settings like
the concert stage for the art gallery as
Charlton Gillespie notes a strict
computational media platform needs an
infrastructure that supports the design
and use of particular applications but
as well as me also documents the terms
extended out were inferring computation
invoking its architectural and
figurative and political meetings too so
that to quote platforms are platforms
not necessarily
because they lack code to be written run
because they afford an opportunity to
communicate cracked or sell this
definition certainly fits settings like
art gallery whose infrastructures for
interactive works often include
computational resources alongside of
architectural space in human later
questions we are increasingly used to
asking about rhythmic platforms
questions about curation representation
transparency are all good questions that
ask that these older types of spaces and
institutions where we run the risk of
taking for granted the metaphor of a
black box assistant whose inputs and
outputs are fluid but whose mechanism is
sealed that's been taken apart from its
algorithmic context by critics opposed
to that inscrutable ax t all kinds of
duties interactive works participate in
the same drive through the ways we
grapple with platforms of course
interactivity is neither an assured or
exclusive way for musicians to further
that cause holly herndon whose latest
album is pictured here is titled
platform grabs Mullen commercial
platforms by their auditory partner to
weaving samples of their sound effects
into song whose lyrics contemplate
intimacy and surveillance interactive
musical works join him at critical
attention at least by necessitating
another platform support software
applications and not just static content
there by amplifying and insistence that
the platforms would listeners experience
music should be more supportive unless
proprietor or only filled in web unless
like YouTube by offering it an
explicitly and uniquely founded space to
the listener interactive musical works
advancement notion that a musical
experience can include testing the
balance of the listening environment and
mindfully entering or choosing not to
enter a relationship with the containers
they formed it brings us to the final
topic listening Jonathan Stern expresses
a concern that an increasingly
corporatized landscape of participatory
culture interactivity might be his words
the new passivity while praising the
20th century arguments from writers like
Natalie and Charles keel that musical
meaning is to be found in participation
stirred wonders if when the rhetoric of
participation is co-opted for the same
sooo marissa purposes that are
facilities serves resisting interactive
media might be the best political corpse
the musicians studied here and many
others have proposed a different tab
Jason Freeman sees and computational
human systems a chance to quote invite
or sometimes even require listeners to
explore a space as that you listen and
to push listening for the creative and
potentially public and collaborative
activity through their use of space
Pauline Oliveros shall appear at leaving
what she calls a deep listening workshop
reimagine much earlier the possibilities
for musical events that develop through
the process of listening many of the
workers took the form instructions
asking a group of listeners while
attending foremost to themselves
listening to bring a piece let me 2 p.m.
one such were cloned his name required
software for people that title caster
work is not just predicting but
continuous with the software based
interactive works we've seen here at the
same time it cleverly asserts that part
of under lease are part of the same
agenda these works advanced that soft
version work for it with upon people
listeners again have always had an
important role to play in instantiated
recorded music awards yet this
responsibility seemed to retro actively
diminished for fixed musical recordings
when you through the lens of the medium
where they now fight channels to reach
us new platforms that the liver music
have at the same time in many cases
found ways to further diminish that
responsibility for example when you
listen to the album streaming service
and Spotify and then attend the platform
continues on into another album deemed
to be similar alleviating you of
decisions like whether to keep listening
as to whether as both conceptions of old
media ends enemies algorithmic
intrusions push passivity on to
listening interactive musical works
seized on listening as an act that is
always in that with meaning
responsibility and consequence thanks so
much
I'm just wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about how this kind of
interactivity in this kind of artwork
might push us to understand platforms in
new ways I just I just I like the use of
platform I I do I think it's a very
useful new word that a lot of people are
picking up on and yet to me there's
something something a little special
about this idea of platforms in this
kind of hard work that you're showing
and I'm wondering if you have ideas
about how you might carve out that
special space for you like why does
interactive music show us something that
like Facebook is a platform doesn't show
us or Twitter as a platform doesn't show
us yeah it's a great question and get
that March part y de femmes 12
Gillespie's platform politics writing be
so helpful i'm thinking about this and
because he starts out by kind of
identifying where this definition that's
being kind of steered by media
industries and that youtube is sort of
its primary example totally thing that
frames itself or service that brings
himself as a platform uses that term to
a wide a lot of feet what kills edges of
this platform the conditions that are
focused on what kind of work shown there
what work is removed and he frames that
term is kind of that new musicians kind
of stemming from the computational sense
but then drying in as I mentioned these
figurative architectural and political
senses and the political sentence is
really that call something a platform it
means there's no kind of bias that goes
into into that state which obviously
there's some tensions
so partly why I think interactive music
would work start exciting is that they
take this former familiar with which is
the song and by kind of giving it the
sex recognition of interactivity
basically require that it needs to be
hosted by an open platform or a platform
in the script original content a total
sense that is something that can play
host to computer program like a web
browser rather looks on my facebook that
goes to image or sound violently and I
think that's an interesting way of
politicizing see different meanings that
industry notion of platform is pulled
from and creating kind of a low sites to
push back along that access I think
that's only the start and kind of you
know what the that doesn't give you
every internet interactive musical work
with like a complete political agenda
works like jazz computer can have to you
know form their own critique on top of
that layer of interactivity in order to
the domain a compelling argument but i
do think as a category it does let us
say that there's this kind of
Oh
because
it sort of seems like what you think
about that
yes that's a fantastic question and
really gets ugly one of the things that
excited me about this type of work in
first place which is to discover when
you talk to these artists that they
don't really think that the interactive
musical whirring fizzling a song that
has attracted evil photography for all
of these artists especially Packard the
musical work that they were doing was
already kind of this cross sensory
collaborative nature that would be
heavily constrained by trying to bend
like transpose it into the recording and
this product for me kind of originated
as wanting to understand how these types
of works sort of know hello kind of
polemic against the recording and I
think that's something that they do it's
sort of revealing the reporting which is
like really in the modern era structured
how it's come to be in many contexts who
would think of the default is the
default apparatus for like musical works
making their way from the artist to us
alongside live some things that do feel
so really a lot of these works rather
than building on top of the recording
kind of show how like though the
recordings constraints are a natural in
the first place and how these things
that we think of it these soccerbase
pieces that we might think of this more
complex or involved just because they
have this basis in software engine
strains translations or distributions of
musical conception to the listener and